das ist wirklich ziemlich mysteriös seit
einiger zeit verhält sich das
supermassereiche schwarze loch im
zentrum unserer galaxie äußerst
gespenstisch sagittarius stern sendet
merkwürdige lichter aus ein schwarzes
loch quasi mit einem kuriosen
heiligenschein
also was ist genau da los klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt's täglich
faszinierend des seins videos abonniert
den kanal aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpassen sie nichts los geht's
willkommen vielen dank für diesen
richtig coolen themen vorschlagen bei
unseren tellern community von sindlingen
der link zur komitee der sehr unter den
der video beschreibungen da könnte eben
themenvorschläge machen diskutieren
abstimmen und so weiter und so fort
zum ersten mal wurde das äußerst
rätselhafte leuchten in einer nacht
mitte mai beobachtet ein forschungsteam
um den astronomen touren so wurde zeuge
davon wie das supermassereiche schwarze
loch im zentrum unserer galaxie
sagittarius stern in einem zeitraum von
nur zwei stunden 75 mal heller wurde als
gewöhnlich ein super mysteriöses
aufleuchten das mit dem hawaiianischen
keck teleskop beobachtet werden konnte
eine echte premiere denn solch hohe
strahlungswerte in dieser wellenlänge
konnten bislang noch nie gemessen werden
klar ist auch dass leuchten kann mit dem
menschlichen auge nicht wahrgenommen
werden denn es liegt im nahen
infrarotbereich für das mentoren von der
university of california in los angeles
ist dieses gespenstische phänomen eine
super große überraschung
ich war zuerst ziemlich überrascht und
dann sehr aufgeregt dazu zwitter der
anfang august hier die übersetzung
aufgenommen als ich im factory x zeigt
dieses leben entstehen hellsten sagen
die tages ein stern der jemals im
infraroten mitte bereich beobachtet
wurde
die mit dem schwarzen noch verbundene
strahlung veränderte sich in dieser
nacht ebenfalls um den faktor 75 macht
sagittarius art verkauft werden wir
endlich eine sternenexplosion sehen und
die sternenexplosion ist mit einem
kleinen budget illustriert wenig später
postete zudem einen spannenden zeit
rabatten in dem das leuchten immer
wieder zu sehen ist und das erstaunen
des wissenschaftlers noch einmal
deutlich wird
hier ist ein zeitraffer des
supermassiven schwarzen lochs tage sagt
stern mit allen zweieinhalb stunden
aufgenommenen bildern vom krieg software
adobe aus dem mai das schwarze loch ist
immer variabel aber dies war das erste
das wir bisher im infrarotbereich
gesehen haben es war wahrscheinlich noch
heller als wir diese nacht zu beobachten
begannen als wären solche massemonster
wie sagittarius stern nicht schon
mysteriös genug für forschungsteams
weltweit sind schwarze löcher immer noch
ein großes mysterium doch klar ist
sagittarius erstellen ist ein echter
superstar unter ihm
er weist rund viereinhalb millionen mal
so viel masse auf wie unsere sonne und
ist innerhalb des universums 26 1500
lichtjahre von uns entfernt also in
unserer milchstraße
doch obwohl es schon seit 20 jahren
intensiv beobachtet wird wurden die
höchstwerte seien bislang gemessene
strahlung in dieser besonderen nacht
verdoppelt in der vergangenheit galt das
zentrum dieses schwarzen locken ist
unter fachleuten als wenig aktiv mit nur
minimalen helligkeitsschwankungen doch
die neuen beobachtungen zeigen jetzt
dass sich die händigkeit von sagittarius
stern ständig ändert es kann innerhalb
von stunden ja sogar minuten heller
leuchten oder schwächer werden das
forschungsteam selbst vergleicht die
beobachtungen mit dem flackern eines
kerzenlicht doch die fachleute selbst
tappen bezüglich einer möglichen
erklärung noch im dunkeln
derzeit werden zwei möglichkeiten
diskutiert zum einen könnte eine
staubwolke auf das schwarze loch
getroffen sein
konkret kommt die staubwolken mit der
bezeichnung geht zwei in frage die vor
fünf jahren 2014 an dem massemonster
vorbeigezogen war damals haben experten
und experten spekulieren dass dank
italiens sternen diese staubwolke
zerreißen würde
letzten endes konnte damals aber nichts
in dieser richtung beobachten werden
handelte es sich bei dem aufleuchten in
der mainacht also um eine verzögerte
reaktion des schwarzen lochs auf die
staubwolke an andere ursache für das
leuchten könnte das zusammentreffen von
sagittarius erstand mit einem
gigantischen stern sein so2 ist 15 mal
so madsen sin wie unsere sonne und
zurück im vergangenen jahr 2018 in einem
abstand von nur 17 licht stunden am
schwarzen loch vorbei an licht stunden
entspricht ungefähr 1,08 milliarden
kilometer in astronomischen dimension
ist das quasi nichts dadurch könnten
sich gase am ereignishorizont
aufgewirbelt worden seien die das
schwarze loch zum leuchten gebracht
haben mit dem ereignishorizont wird in
der fachsprache der äußere rand eines
schwarzen lochs bezeichnen hier würden
extreme gezeitenkräfte in die gaswolken
oder sterne anziehen und regelrecht
verschlingen
diese heizen sich dabei auf so dass dann
mit hilfe von teleskopen helle blitze zu
beobachten sind die fachleute um den
astronomen turbo sind sich nicht sicher
ob das mysteriöse aufleuchten auch in
der nächsten zeit weiter gehen wird sie
haben das ansonsten auf jeden fall im
visier
doch schon bald wird ihnen die sonne
einen strich durch die rechnung machen
denn diese wird sich vor den himmels
ausschnitt schieben und den blick auf
das schwarze loch erst einmal versperren
war es von den themen setzen große
hoffnung auf weitere teleskope wie das
spitzer weltraumteleskop diese könnten
weitere wichtige daten sammeln um den
mysteriösen heiligenschein des schwarzen
lochs zu erklären und somit endlich
licht in die sache zu bringen
wie sieht ein schwarzes loch aus dass
erklärt jakob von breaking lab extrem
spannendes video anklicken anschauen und
natürlich breaking lab abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran